we think that the plastic water bottle
is the same as like turning off your
fertility no what I'm saying is that
there's like a lot of like clear
evidence and data that shows that the
products that you know like micro
Plastics they go into our blood they
like affect our like hormones they
affect our fertility there's like clear
there's more clear data showing other
things that we consume that have major
effects on fertility
but I just I just think there's some
things I can like get through common
sense right I mean I think I think it's
common sense if you turn off your
fertility that's gonna be the biggest
effect that you can have on your
fertility